well mental health and treating it has
really been discussed a lot more openly
in recent years but it's no secret there
simply are not enough resources to
handle a crisis now a local hospital is
doubling its capacity to help with
treatment at least here in the valley
eight news now reporter Ryan Matthey
shows us there is a warning here you
might find some of the details here
somewhat sensitive
Desert Winds hospital opened their doors
two years ago just for adolescent youth
with mental health illnesses well now
we're standing in a brand new unit
they've made for adult patients they're
doubling their capacity as a need for
Mental Health Resources is Across the
Nation we tossed her apple one day and
we said you know what you take that
apple and you peel it the same way you
would your skin Kenneth Holland
describing a 12 year old patient who
made it through these doors suffering
with self-harm every time she wanted to
cut herself they had her peel an apple
you look up 30 minutes later that Apple
was bald unconventional treatments
utilized here as emergency room beds run
full but not necessarily full of Staff
the problem exacerbated even more during
pandemic restrictions and a stigma
around mental health adults don't get
the level of services that they used to
but as Clinical Services director Adina
Archibald says age does not dictate
mental illness insurance company quote
wizard reported this year that 21
percent of nevadans have some form of a
mental illness it ranks the state eighth
for worst access to mental health care
in the country with only 4 out of 10
people receiving care this hospital soon
adding nearly a hundred more beds like
these to help alleviate emergency room
burdens and cut back the need to send
patients out of state for treatment
there's chemical imbalances trauma is a
big big thing this is that place to stay
this is that place Senator Catherine
Cortez masto received a tour of the
expansion Thursday we do not have enough
resources acknowledging her efforts to
secure funding for the 988 Crisis
Hotline mobile crisis units and
allocations for mental health services
in covid relief packages the fiscal year
2024 presidential budget includes nearly
11 billion dollars for Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Services and beds like
these will become available for adult
patients beginning July 17th reporting
at Desert Winds Hospital Ryan Matthey a
news now